good evening everybody
as you've seen by now this isn't a
normal convention
it's not a normal time so
tonight i want to talk as plainly as i
can
about the stakes in this election
because what we do these next 76 days
will echo through generations to come
i'm in philadelphia where our
constitution was drafted
and signed it wasn't a perfect document
it allowed for the inhumanity of slavery
and failed to guarantee women and even
men who didn't own property
the right to participate in the
political process
but embedded in this document was a
north star that would guide future
generations
a system of representative government a
democracy
through which we could better realize
our highest ideals
through civil war and bitter struggles
we improved this constitution to include
the voices of those
who'd once been left out and gradually
we made this country
more just and more equal
and more free
the one constitutional office elected by
all of the people is the presidency
so to minimum we should expect a
president to feel a sense of
responsibility
for the safety and welfare of all 330
million of us regardless of what we look
like
how we worship who we love how much
money we have
or who we voted for
but we should also expect a president to
be the custodian of this democracy
should expect that regardless of ego
ambition
or political beliefs the president will
preserve
protect and defend the freedoms and
ideals that
so many americans marched for went to
jail for
fought for and died for
i have sat in the oval office with both
of the men who are running for president
i never expected that my successor would
embrace my vision
or continue my policies
i did hope for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show some
interest
in taking the job seriously
that he might come to feel the weight of
the office
and discover some reverence for the
democracy
that had been placed in his care
he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office
to help anyone but himself and his
friends
no interest in treating the presidency
as anything but one more reality show
that he can use
to get the attention he craves
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
and the consequences of that failure are
severe
170 000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone well those at the
top
taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
now i know that in times as polarized as
these
most of you have already made up your
mind
but maybe you're still not sure which
candidate you'll vote for
or whether you'll vote at all
maybe you're tired of the direction
we're headed but you can't
see a better path yet or you just don't
know enough about the person
who wants to lead us there
so let me tell you about my friend joe
biden
12 years ago when i began my search for
a vice president
i didn't know i'd end up finding a
brother
joe and i come from different places
different generations but
what i quickly came to admire about
joe biden is his resilience born of too
much struggle
his empathy born of too much grief
joe is a man who learned early on to
treat
every person he meets with respect and
dignity
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe
but you're better than nobody
that empathy that decency
the belief that everybody counts
that's who joe is
when he talks with someone who's lost
her job joe remembers the night his
father sat him down to say
that he'd lost his
when joe listens to a parent who's
trying to hold it
all together right now he does it
as a single dad who took the train back
to
wilmington each and every night so he
could tuck his kids into bed
when he meets with military families
who've lost their hero
he does it as a kindred spirit the
parent
of an american soldier somebody whose
faith has endured
the hardest loss there is
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room whenever
i faced a big decision he made me a
better president
and he's got the character and the
experience to make us
a better country and in my friend
kamala harris he's chosen an ideal
partner
who is more than prepared for the job
someone who knows what it's like to
overcome barriers and who's made a
career
fighting to help others live out their
own american dream
along with the experience needed to get
things done joe and kamala
have concrete policies that will turn
their vision of a better fairer stronger
country
into reality they will get this pandemic
under control
like joe did when he helped me manage
h1n1
and prevent an ebola outbreak from
reaching our shores
they'll expand health care to more
americans like joe and i did 10 years
ago
when he helped craft the affordable care
act and nail down the votes to make it
the law
they'll rescue the economy like joe
helped me do after the great recession
i asked him to manage the recovery act
which jump started the longest stretch
of job growth in history
and he sees this moment now not as a
chance to get back to where we were
but to make long overdue changes so that
our economy actually makes life a little
easier for everybody whether it's the
waitress trying to
raise a kid on her own or the shift
worker
always on the edge of getting laid off
or the student
figuring out how to pay for next
semester's classes
joe and kamala will restore our standing
in the world and as we've learned from
this pandemic
that matters joe knows the world
and the world knows him
he knows that our true strength comes
from setting an example
that the world wants to follow a nation
that stands with democracy
not dictators a nation that can inspire
and mobilize others to overcome threats
like climate change and terrorism
poverty and disease
but more than anything what i know
about joe what i know about kamala
is that they actually care about every
american
and that they care deeply about this
democracy
they believe that in a democracy
the right to vote is sacred and we
should be making it easier for people to
cast their ballots
not harder
they believe that no one including the
president
is above the law and that no public
official
including the president should use their
office
to enrich themselves or their supporters
they understand that in this democracy
the commander-in-chief
does not use the men and women of our
military who are willing to risk
everything to protect our nation as
political props to deploy against
peaceful protesters on our own soil
they understand that political opponents
aren't un-american just because they
disagree with you
a free press isn't the enemy but the way
we
hold officials accountable that our
ability to work together to solve big
problems like a pandemic
depend on a fidelity to facts and
science
and logic and not just making stuff up
none of this should be controversial
these shouldn't be republican principles
or democratic principles they are
american principles but at this moment
this president and those who enable them
have shown they don't believe in these
things
tonight i'm asking you to believe in joe
and kamala's ability to lead this
country out of these dark times and
build it back better
but here's the thing no single american
can fix this country alone not even a
president
democracy was never meant to be
transactional you give me your vote i
make
everything better it requires an active
and informed citizenry
so i'm also asking you to believe in
your own ability
to embrace your own responsibility as
citizens
to make sure that the basic tenets of
our democracy endure
because that's what's at stake right now
our democracy
look i understand why
a lot of americans are down on
government
the way the rules have been set up and
abused in congress make it easier
for special interests to stop progress
than to make progress
believe me i i know it i understand why
a
white factory worker who's seen his
wages cut or his job shipped overseas
might feel like
the government no longer looks out for
him
and why a black mom might feel like it
never looked out for her at all
i understand why a new immigrant might
look around this country and wonder
whether there's still a place for him
here
why a young person might look at
politics right now
the circus of it all the meanness and
the lies
and conspiracy theories and think
what is the point
well here's the point this president
and those in power those who benefit
from keeping things
the way they are they are counting on
your cynicism
they know they can't win you over with
their policies
so they're hoping to make it as hard as
possible
for you to vote and to convince you that
your vote does not matter
that is how they win that is how they
get to keep making decisions that affect
your life
and the lives of the people you love
that's how the economy will keep getting
skewed to the wealthy and well connected
how our health systems will let more
people fall through the cracks
that's how a democracy withers until
it's no democracy at all
and we cannot let that happen
do not let them take away your power
do not let them take away your democracy
make a plan right now for how you are
going to get involved
and vote do it as early as you can
and tell your family and friends how
they can vote too
do what americans have done for over two
centuries when
faced with even tougher times than this
all those quiet heroes who found the
courage to keep marshy
keep pushing in the face of hardship
and injustice
last month we lost a giant of american
democracy
in john lewis and some years ago i sat
down with john
and a few remaining leaders of
the early civil rights movement
one of them told me he never imagined
he'd walk into the white house
and see a president who looked like his
grandson
and then he told me that he had looked
it up
and it turned out that on the very day
that i was born
he was marching into a jail cell
trying to end jim crow segregation in
the south
what we do echoes
through generations
whatever our backgrounds we are all the
children of americans who fought the
good fight
great grandparents working in fire traps
and sweatshops without rights
or representation farmers
losing their dreams to dust
irish and italians and asians and
latinos told
go back where you come from
jews and catholics muslims and sikhs
made to feel suspect for the way they
worshipped
black americans chained and whipped
and hanged spit on
for trying to sit at lunch counters
beaten for trying to vote
if anyone had a right to believe that
this democracy
did not work and could not work
it was those americans our ancestors
they were on the receiving end of a
democracy that had fallen short
all their lives
they knew how far the daily reality of
america strayed from the mint
and yet instead of giving up they joined
together
and they said somehow some way we are
going to make this work
we are going to bring those words
in our founding documents to life
i have seen that same spirit rising
these past few years
folks of every age and background who
packed city centers and airports and
rural roads so that families wouldn't be
separated
so that another classroom wouldn't get
shot up
so that our kids won't grow up on an
uninhabitable planet
americans of all races joining together
to declare
in the face of injustice
and brutality at the hands of the state
that black lives matter no more
but no less so that no child in this
country
feels the continuing sting of racism
to the young people who led us this
summer telling
us we need to be better
in so many ways you are this country's
dreams fulfilled
earlier generations had to be persuaded
that everyone
has equal worth for you it's a given
a conviction
and what i want you to know is that for
all its messiness and frustrations
your system of self-government
can be harnessed to help you realize
those convictions for all of us
you can give our democracy new meaning
you can take it to a better place
you're the missing ingredient the ones
who will decide whether or not
america becomes the country that fully
lives up to its creed
that work will continue long after this
election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy
down if that's what it takes for them to
win
so we have to get busy building it up
by pouring all our efforts into these 76
days
and by voting like never before for joe
and kamala
and candidates up and down the ticket
so that we leave no doubt about
what this country that we love
stands for today
and for all our days to come
stay safe god bless